besides the precise gun play what helps
valrant stand out from its competitors
like cs go
are the unique agents players are able
to utilize valerian has been out for
over a year now and it seems like all
right is able to hear some days is fix
your damn agents those ask the age-old
question
are any agents of the game actually
broken
or
is it the players themselves that make
the agents broken
[Music]
before we get into the video i have to
remind you to like comment and subscribe
and don't forget to hit that
notification bell alright i want you to
picture this you finished a few death
matches you hop into discord with your
friends or people you tolerate not to
tank your rr you have discussion about
your team composition and then
bam you see that the probably smurfs
you're queuing against have running the
team comp of reyna jet silva skye and
sage no this isn't berlin this is your
reality baby on a serious note i'm here
to answer the question old does valerian
itself are there any broken agents you
know agents that are not good for the
game and need to be fixed in order for
the game to have a healthy long run i
see it on twitter and i see it every
single time i lock in kj and one of you
in chat tells me that i need to get good
at the game and stop relying on my
turret i know i need to get good at the
game don't remind me i'm working on it
but let's break this down what do we
mean by broken do we mean they're too
hard to play against too easy to play
maybe they let the player make a ton of
mistakes or there's no way to counter
play them before we decide if these
agents if any are broken we need to
agree on a definition you know so we're
on the same page so into the world's
greatest resource urban dictionary to
get the real definition of broken
according to scholar
dum dum broken one characterizing game
mechanics are objects that are so
powerful that they trivialize game
content or become the only desirable
items or mechanics for a player to use
two describing any combination of
character class mechanics and equipment
which is too difficult or impossible for
skilled players to reliably counter in
player versus player combat don't come
at me for using herbert dictionary i
know they're a reliable source because
their definition for elizabeth and s is
this elizabeth is a beautiful girl
yeah sorry jokes aside i think we can
all agree this is a pretty well-rounded
definition of broken so let's say an
agent is broken if it trivializes valor
by being the only desirable choice for a
player or it is too difficult for a
skilled player to reliably counter so
which agents fill this description first
up let's take a look at jet jet is one
of the agents the community has always
been shouting about being broken jet's
movement is what makes her the most
unique agent in the game no one else's
kit has the same ability to peak riskier
angles push harder and faster and get
out of trouble at a moment's notice just
watch how cned uses the op and dash for
a terrifying yet inspiring 4k
plays are as well they're full
committing to it a late lurk by poor
coming in through middle as they claim
the side and now look for the plan but
income cnet gonna make it at least a
little bit costly there's absolutely no
way that this player steps up above he's
challenged cena and he's received
exactly what you'd expect another scene
and just keeps on going three kills with
the off a tag into another and this is
getting scary with just one down below
trapped in russ needs to make something
happen while flora is making the short
play lurking out trying to find space
but cena picks up four on his stream
shazam told everyone why jet being the
only viable operator agent is a problem
okay
the
the gun the op is only viable on jet and
that's a problem in my opinion it's too
clunky to use on any other agent and the
problem is is that there's no there's
not a lot of counter options to the up
now if you could use the op on other
agents you can counter a jet just
walking up with an opera or a jet just
taking a duel at dry peak players may
have another operator agent soon though
and his name is chamber chambers
ultimate toward the force equips him
with a heavy sniper rifle that kills on
any direct hit and slows enemies
surrounding the down target
[Music]
[Music]
chamber is set to be released november
16th and will have to see if he can take
jet's operator crown historically though
she's always been the queen just for
some perspective jet was a part of team
comps 85 percent of the time at masters
berlin then at a 64 rate we have silva
so this kit is an info grabbing damage
dealing monster and as silva you don't
need to be standing right at an entryway
to use your util you can be across an
entire map and just bounce a little guy
twice and then boom phi pink show up on
your screen hiko proves time and time
again that just one arrow can stop an
entire push
under thieves once more find themselves
on the back foot and we've seen how some
of these can turn out
four or five emperors
three seconds until dart that's going to
be their cue to push i'm pretty sure oh
no they won't even get that far
that okay i can dart when they come out
tens if you call it
yeah yeah darting it's like it's a god
dart
i got pings
oh
and then we have our favorite built
australian skye skye's rapid heel and
her dog are great what makes skye so
opie are her flashes her flashes give
and tell and are also able to be piloted
by the players somewhat frankly skye's
flashes do a lot for just being flashes
sky gets a sound cue whether or not
people are blinded even through smokes
or even when she's blinded and if you
really want to get op with it you can
use sky splashes to fake flash and catch
your enemy off guard so rosa shows just
how her flashes can leave a sky main to
get some easy pickings and his kill
before this clip was thanks to a flash
and then our local favorite
raina
the arena site last player standing
[Music]
there you're going
oh i got so unlucky reina is able to
receive no damage for a small yet
significant amount of time heal and then
overheal and also throw out blinds that
don't affect her own team no i'm not
making this up those are her very real
completely acceptable abilities that
don't make me mauled whatsoever being
able to have her entire team peak using
her own blinds that can easily be thrown
up right after one another is
infuriating and to be rewarded for each
kill just seems like favoritism from
riot i've said it before and i'll say it
again reina's util is made for smurfs
playing at a higher skill level than
literally everyone in your lobby means
that once you get that overheal going
it's game over for everyone else so if
you're a raynoman i would like to take
this opportunity to tell you exactly
what i think about you and that is
you're doing great keep it up i'm proud
of you
take your meds today to drink your water
good for you but i digress the important
thing to note about reina is that while
she completely destroys us casuals she's
not really favored in the pro scene
let's play a little game what do you
think her pick rate was at masters
berlin the answer is 24
how about masters reykjavik 5
the thing about reina is that she
rewards getting a lot of frags and the
people that seek them out but the people
that seek them out have to be stellar at
shooting if they aren't her blind's a
waste and she's going down rayna is a
great individual agent for those of you
who want to destroy some people in
unrated but in terms of team comp she
doesn't really offer much besides her
push and her blind and she'll run out of
those quickly she literally makes holes
in the team she's a part of because of
her lack of util so use it for your
youtube highlights
not for the open qualifiers unless you
are positive you can absolutely crush
everyone that comes your way and if you
have that type of confidence and skill
please tell me how you got that the
reason she isn't used in the pros scene
as much as she is at your level and mine
is because as a pro you're playing
people who are if not as good better
than you and they'll have the util to
combat you basically she's underpowered
in the pro scene riot looks at a couple
of things and one of the most important
places is the pro scene the professional
scene in valentine is still in its
relative infancy yet pros help dictate
how us casuals play the game and what
riot responds to well i'm thinking about
a certain viper nerf after berlin right
not despite making up an incredibly
small percentage of the valerian
community pros are influential in how we
see the game and how riot sees the game
and rise september state of the agents
they had this to say we just came off
the heels of watching stage 3 masters
yes it was awesome so now is the time
you take to digest all the play styles
strats etc from the tournament and see
what changes could or should be made
based off of those high tier games there
is a discussion to be had about certain
agents and how they're chosen in every
single professional match so team comps
are incredibly predictable but that's
the pro scene broken agents at the
professional level does not mean they're
broken at every level ride has a super
difficult job when it comes to balance
of players in like silver one versus
radiance agents serve different purposes
at different skill levels and different
skill levels are only able to optimally
use certain abilities i'm sorry but i'm
not going to trust a day one race flying
across the map with her blast packs and
timing it with her ult
nor would i expect that but agents are
still adjusted every now and then
according to pro play this is super
important for riot because they have to
keep their pro scene as balanced as
possible the pros are the leaders in the
scene they help to set the tempo pro
players are showing off riot's product
for the entire world to see at the
highest level it needs to be in tip-top
shape so how many patches nerfs or buffs
has each agent received well once again
because i love you all so much i went
back into every single patch note and
broke out excel and did some
calculations the math i did shows this
basically every agent has received
pretty much the same amount of attention
meaning that their skills were directly
addressed by riot whether it was a nerf
or a buff some have fewer because they
haven't been in the game as long but one
patch note could be a variety of changes
for an agent not just one thing just as
an example let's see how riot approaches
agents when they need to make a change
riot said themselves regarding sky and
ko that in some ways even the smallest
tweaks can result in the biggest
differences when it comes to the impact
of flashes so as you'll see in the patch
3.06 changes we provided a few light
touches on those two initiators the goal
here is to increase ko's viability
reduce some of the frustrating parts of
playing against sky like how fast she
can capitalize on her flash if these
tweaks are not enough we'll move the
needle around until they are in a good
spot promise so
what have we learned are any agents
broken invalorent
they're gonna hate me but no an agent is
only broken as the player is good agents
like jet arena already lend themselves
to skilled players destroying others but
again agent is to broken as cracked is
to player welcome to any game ever where
some characters are just better more
popular choices than others and even a
proto agrees with me on this broken
hmm
i don't know i think there's some really
good agents like silva astro i think
they're insanely good but i don't think
they're broken astra was broken and i
think the things they did to fix her
made her
uh worse she's still the best controller
by far um so i think that that's not
because she's really good i think that's
all because they need work they need
fixes to their kids
like there's no reason to ever touch a
brand in this game over astra
or omen and even then the gap between
omen and astra is still pretty big too
so
um
i think
there's not really broken characters but
there's ones you should definitely aim
to use we may not have a broken agent
per se but that's not to say we will
necessarily never have one if a buff
becomes too great and isn't addressed or
somehow we have a new agent that has the
best of all abilities in one
then yeah we have an issue there if we
see an agent that absolutely has to be
chosen for your team's success
then we'll have a conversation about
that agent but as of right now we really
don't have that situation valerian is
still very much a game based on your
team composition so at the end of the
day personally i don't think any agents
are broken by their design alone it is
the player that makes them broken i
would be a terrible jet i've tried it
once never again however i have gotten
many people in all chat telling me to
get a life by using my killjoy util and
that took me time to learn and adapt
and there my dears is the point of an
agent at all please feel free to leave
me your three-point thesis statement in
the comment section below as to why jet
is like actually really broken and i'm
an idiot i promise i'll read it and take
it to heart and i mean we all know the
most broken age involves brimstone
but that's just between us
and then we have our favorite built
australian sky
hawkeye
tokyo
that's my favorite one
when she oh my favorite line of hers
when she's like 4 a.m run if you lose or
something like that i'm like okay